C'est pas ce qui était prévu mais...
Attends... La porte d'entrée est ouverte c'est chelou...
Ouverte ? Pas fermée à clé ou ouverte ouverte ?
Putain, Ben ! Quelqu'un sait... La maison a été fouillée !
Alyssa, c’est sûrement Gadock !
Il est dans la maison !
Tire-toi de là !
Alyssa !
T'inquiète pas.
Je suis cachée.
Comment ça cachée ? T’es cachée où ?
Derrière le canapé.
Sors de là !
Tu sais ce que je veux et tu veux rester en vie, alors gagnons du temps...
Dis-moi tout de suite où...
Messieurs-dames, votre attention s'il-vous-plaît, il y a des travaux sur la ligne. Une douzaine d'arrêts, ne seront pas desservis.
Où est le dernier œil gauche ?
Ah... Ah j'entends pas du tout ce que vous dites.
Dis-moi où est le dernier œil gauche ou je t'explose la cervelle.
De quoi ?
Bon écoutez-moi bien.
Oui, je vous écoute.
Beh, vous m'entendez...
Non.
...Donc si vous m'écoutez, vous m'entendez.
En fait, je pense que vous vous m'entendez mieux que moi je vous entends.
J'ai un problème d'audition.
Mais c'est quoi ? Vous avez une autite ? C'est ça ?
Ouais, beh c'est un début d'autite, oui.
C'est quand on met la tête sous l'eau froide...
Oui... Je fais de la plongée.
Beh cherchez pas c'est ça.
...Pour votre compréhension. Désolé pour la gêne occasionnée.
C'est compliqué aujourd'hui.
Ah ouais, c'est clair laisse tomber.
Où se trouve le dernier œil gauche ?
Messieurs-dames, votre attention s'il-vous-plaît, une deuxième déviation va nous obliger à prendre...
Il est là.
T'as très bien entendu la question !
Non.
Gadock !
Donc t'arrêtes ton petit numéro.
Gadock ! Le dernier œil gauche, il est là !
Tu me réponds !
Donc arrête...
Oh !
Depuis le temps que j’attends ce moment ! Je vais prendre ton œil et accomplir la prophétie...
Quoi ?
Je... Je disais depuis le temps que j'attends ce moment...
Depuis le temps que t'attends maman ?
Non... Moment... Ce moment-là. Cet instant. L'instant présent. Un instant présent.
Tu veux me faire un cadeau ?
Non j'ai pas dit ça.
L'instant présent !
L'instant présent ! Le moment ! Voilà.
Il n'y aucun rapport avec ma mère.
Et de quoi depuis le temps que t'attends ce moment ?
Beh... Je... Je...
Beh continue !
Tu me coupes tout le temps ! Donc comment veux-tu que je tienne après !
Depuis le temps que t'attends ce moment quoi ?
Depuis le temps que j'attends ce moment... Je... Je vais arracher ton œil.
Bon écoute ! Hé ! Je n'entends rien, fais un pas vers moi, je vais t'entendre.
Non ! Non ! Non ! Non !
Quoi ?
Tu me fais avancer et là comme par hasard il va y avoir un piège.
Je suis sûr sous la moquette il y a une trappe avec des lions... Ou des merdes comme ça !
Tu crois que je suis un bleu ?
Non.
T'as qu'à lire sur mes lèvres. Parce qu'on n'arrive pas à se faire comprendre là.
Tu vas tout de suite me donner ton œil gauche...
Sinon... Je vais te tuer.
Je sais pas lire sur les lèvres...
Oh putain !
Hé les gars ! Vous prenez pas la tête, elle regarde pas de toute façon !
Mais putain mais ! Elle va durer combien de temps son annonce à lui là ?
Ah non mais là l'annonce elle est finie là ! Elle parle avec le gars.
Sérieusement ? Pfou !
Il se passe quoi ?
Sarah qui parle avec un mec là !
Ouais putain elle pourrait mettre pause, on est en train de vivre un moment super important là.
Oui.
Ah ouais... Laisse tomber, je suis grave d'accord avec toi.
Mais on l'attend non ?
Beh oui on l'attend.
Tu t'appelles comment ?
Sarah.
Ok, Zack, enchanté.
Enchantée.
Tu regardes quoi ?
Kennewick.
Ah ouais, on m'a dit que c'était pas mal ça.
Ah c'est trop ouf ! Moi j'adore perso.
Et beh mets pause alors...
Je vais essayer.
Et toi tu regardes quoi ?
Euh... Iron Viking.
Ok, c'est bien ça ?
Ça va.
Ça fait mal ça.
Et je t'ai jamais vue dans le bus c'est la première fois que tu le prends ?
Ah beh non, je le prends tous les jours pour aller à la fac, moi...
Ah ouais ?
Parce que c'est la première fois que je vois tes yeux.
Beh je veux dire, si j'avais déjà vu tes yeux, je m'en serais souvenu.
Oh le lourd !
Ah ok d'accord...
Non c'était naze...
Ouais grave désolée !
C'était lourd !
T'es à la fac ?
Ouais je suis à la fac, en psycho.
Et mes horaires, c'est un peu n'importe quoi. Du coup parfois, je suis pas dans le bus...  Enfin Bref.
Parfois t'es pas dans le bus ?
Ouais.
Bon on abrège là ? C'est pas vrai !
Et toi t'es en quoi ?
Moi je suis en ciné.
Ok, c'est cool ?
Ouais, c'est cool ouais.
Ouais.
Et c'est quoi genre les cours ?
On étudie l'histoire du cinéma...
On fait des analyses de films, un peu...
Yes ! Mais yes quoi !
Super ! En pleine bataille finale ? Alors que je viens de perdre mon meilleur ami !
Pas encore tout à fait...
C'est cool parce que le gars ça faisait longtemps qu'elle l'avait repéré.
Attends... T'emballes pas non plus c'est pas fait ! Hein ! Attention.
Gadock a raison, c'est pas parce qu'elle a éteint son portable qu'ils vont forcément se pécho.
J'allais te défoncer ! C'est un moment fatidique !
Il va revenir Haldack. Allez mets-toi bien. Tu vas me défoncer.
C'est ici que Gadock a émis un signal pour la dernière fois !
Donc ça correspond ! Le professeur avait raison.
Ça ne fait aucun doute, ça correspond parfaitement.
Cette fois-ci c'est nous qui avons un coup d'avance sur lui.
C'est peut-être notre dernière chance d'arrêter la prophétie.
Hé, regarde.
Ils sont trop mignons.
Tu sais qu'hier, ils ont parlé de s'installer ensemble.
Non ? Trop bien.
Bon, beh il a lâché la série, il reviendra pas.
Il partage son compte avec son petit frère, moi je mise tout sur le petit frère.
C'est une petite sœur qu'il a.
Ah.
J'avoue c'est chaud...
Clap !
Action !
J'ai jamais réussi à faire ces conneries.
Et voilà !
Fais voir j'en essaye une comme ça.
Je te jure, je fais pas exprès.
Action !
Top ! Coupé !
Ça y est !
Bravo !